let's jump to this story from the
post-millennial breaking Arizona Supreme
Court revives Kerry Lake claim on
signature verification so uh we'll I'll
give you the simple version
Kerry Lake filed numerous claims
they were dismissed by a lower court
Kerry Lake appealed and one very
important component one of the most
important made it through now the
corporate press is saying carry a lake
mostly loses appeal
if you're filing a lawsuit like this you
don't just say here's my one complaint
you get as many as you can and throw
them all out there scatter shot and then
see which ones stick and Carrie Lake got
one signature verification when the the
the the argument is uh uh not just in
Kerry Lake's case but in Trump as well
the argument is too many signatures got
accepted that should not have that many
of these probably didn't match but they
were letting them through anyway when
Kerry Lake sued they said this is a
procedure question and you should have
sued before the election well now the
Appellate Court a supreme court has said
no how would she Sue unless there was
something done that she can sue over go
back and redo this for all we know the
lower court just kicks it out again
but it's entirely possible that they're
forced to take it up the the issue with
Kerry Lake and with any anyone involved
in this is that every single person in
politics save like
I don't know five ten people okay to be
fair maybe 50. uh they're cowards
they're all cowards I'm I've I've been
uh I feel like DeSantis is a letdown I
feel like he is too weak Carrie lake is
strong Trump is strong I like that there
are a decent number of strong people in
Congress Matt Gates standing up to Kevin
McCarthy was absolutely fantastic
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert
despite the fact Roger Taylor green was
in favor of Kevin McCarthy she's stood
up on a lot of issues but I look at
these these these court cases and these
judges and everyone's just like oh man I
don't want to do this I don't want to be
involved so what I guess I would say is
you know aside from this story I feel
like a big thing that's being revealed
right now is just how cowardly so much
of our society and and government is how
many individuals are
probably why people voted for Trump
probably why people like Carrie Lake
they want someone who's finally just
going to stand up and say screw off
by the way cowardice and politics is not
a new phenomenon oh yeah but but I but I
feel like it's it's more widespread and
and culturally ingrained at this point
yeah like I I maybe I'm just wrong but I
kind of feel like if you go back 100
years you find most people weren't
cowardly although they were cowards
maybe it's more exposed because I think
I think you know we We complain about
all the downsides of social media I
think one of the powerful things that
happens is that you realize that most
politicians are telling you what you
want to hear without ever saying
anything and you can dig a little bit
deeper now and you realize that they're
empty suits so when we see someone who
appears to be saying what they actually
think and I think Carrie lake is
absolutely one of those people that in
and of itself regardless of what she's
saying is appealing to people because
she's actually speaking what she thinks
and she's not attractive and she's not
dropping it I mean it would have been
easy for her to say like this is corrupt
and terrible and then quietly Fade Into
the background right I mean she must be
spending tons of money on this legal
battle and yet she thinks it's worth it
she's standing by what she said that she
needs to stand up for Arizona voting
integrity and so she's going to push it
for as long as she can and I I think
there is something refreshing about that
right it's it's very different than
someone saying like this was stolen from
me or this was unfair and then kind of
doing nothing I think a lot of Voters
are very sick of the inaction the fact
that they don't fall through with
anything yeah
no it's kind of telling that when you
search Kerry Lake you see a host of
Articles like robots she mostly loses I
think that's the phrase every article
says the same thing that tells me that
she probably accomplished something yep
because how do you mostly lose if your
goal is to get an argument in they're
like well she mostly lost it's like is
the lawsuit moving forward yes so she
didn't lose well she lost a lot of them
but the lawsuit is moving forward it's
like okay well that sounds like her loss
is moving forward firstly rejected yeah
AP has Arizona Court declines most of
lakes appeal over governor's race and
it's like but they took something you're
trying to frame it as you know she's
this crazy but don't worry she's being
subdued and really you know the issues
that matter and the ones that could make
a difference are are being moved forward
I think a lot of the cowardice and
politics comes from people being able to
communicate from behind a keyboard and a
computer in a locked room like a lot of
stuff people say to each other in social
media they would never say to each other
and face to face I I
look man the DeSantis response to the
Trump indictment stuff was like getting
a bucket of water splashed in the face I
don't care a lot of people are like you
know DeSantis said I don't know what
goes into paying a porn star hush money
or whatever
I don't care that he said that I care
about the fact that he said I'm not
getting involved in this instead of
saying Fu instead of just telling
telling these these lunatics to shove to
screw themselves he probably figures
Trump's pissed off so many people and
he's got no chance at winning and if he
gets involved and gets on his side he'll
just be lumped into that no chance at
winning but I mean he's not wrong that
Trump has pissed off way more people
than he needed to but it does but he
could have said look it's not about
Donald Trump you don't have to like the
guy I've got my differences with him he
calls me a meatball but the idea that a
six-year-old misdemeanor would warrant
extradition from my state is laughable
so do not even try it and he's like come
on where the ball's at just you know I
just don't see it that's what he should
have done yeah it would take him from
being just this suit that's sort of
Towing the line trying to to pick up
both sides you know people who are for
Trump and people who are against him and
give given him a personality right like
he's not willing to take that risk and
that's where you get this fear that he's
becoming like a politician yes and and
who is he trying to win over with this
right the idea is that well a lot of
people don't like Trump and he could win
the never Trump or Republicans dude all
of the parental rights and education
stuff that he's done he's they're lying
about it saying he's Banning books the
Lincoln Project's calling him awful and
evil there's nothing to be gained from
not like from going the route he's going
it may just be simple
I don't know if he intentionally was
trying to avoid being defensive of trump
the fact is he does not have it within
him to be defensive of hard-line
principles in that way so what I when I
see DeSantis I see a guy who you know
early on he's got this policy
accomplishments he's a great Governor I
still think that's true and so you
believe that here's a guy who gets it
and now what you see over the past few
months is here's a guy who's vanilla
pudding who was given the correct script
he's given the proper Playbook he said I
will execute because I can understand
people like this but then when it comes
time to stand in front of the Flames he
goes too much for me there buddy he
doesn't seem like the guy who sent
illegal immigrants to Martha's Vineyard
anymore I don't know that's a good point
I think that's too far I think it was a
tactical mistake and and I think he can
cover from it oh you think that that the
Trump statement stuff yeah yeah I think
the issue though is like the Martha's
Vineyard thing was was masterfully done
and that's the kind of stuff you want to
see
but I kind of i i i half agree with you
I think there's an opportunity for him
to come back and and have that strong
voice but I kind of do feel like this
was a bit revealing and it's not so much
about can he recover from it so much so
as we've learned a little bit about him
but but we'll see we'll see he did a
show with Glenn Beck that was pretty
enlightening I don't know if you guys
saw that it's worth watching I only saw
it so far about 10 minutes of it in fact
I'm not realizing I should watch the
entire thing because it was like oh I
see the humanity in this guy now he's a
tactical guy he's like a Jag he was a
Navy lawyer Jack guy and uh he knows
when to speak when not to speak when to
let your enemy if your enemy's making a
mistake don't stop him that's probably
what he's thinking with Trump right now
he's like dude this guy's foot in his
mouth he deserves this he paid off a
prostitute that he had sex with while he
was married and running for president
like let him burn let him let him let
him deal with it I'm not getting
involved in this crap
uh he wants to win the presidency man if
if DeSantis is the nominee he's got my
vote I like the guy I think he's I think
he's doing really well I think he's a
great Governor I think he'll be a great
leader and I think he's substantially
better than anything anyone else has to
offer
but I understand why people like Trump
because Trump you know you know this is
the thing I said before that descendants
might be a good VP is because
descendants has what Trump doesn't Trump
has what DeSantis doesn't Trump has that
like boastful arrogance about him he is
that guy who's going to be like don't
you try it don't come at me it's not
happening and the sentence is a guy
who's going to be like here's what the
people actually want here's me telling
off the the you know the the lockdowns
and actually
like solving these problems properly
Trump's got the attitude DeSantis has
the plan yeah I can respect that I think
it's it's tough to say what would have
happened should it whatever but I think
if DeSantis had been president when code
struck that he wouldn't have let fauci
run the show he would have run the show
I don't know man he doesn't I mean he's
like he knows how to use the system he
he used his um state of emergency in
Florida and he held it open so that he
could reposition funds to make sure that
schools couldn't close down so it's like
yeah he knew that this coveted crap was
an emergency and it was making kids get
masked when they were two and three so
he's like no the emergency is that kids
are getting massed up at four years old
I'm not gonna let that happen to kids
well that that that's an interesting
question when it comes to actual policy
is Trump the kind of guy who's gonna
drop the hammer or is DeSantis DeSantis
is the guy who sent a bunch of migrants
to Martha's Vineyard as a powerful
statement Trump's the guy who refused to
fire fauci because he was scared of
political backlash so it's tough I like
the Navy lawyer I'm gonna I like the
experience I like having a lawyer in
presidency Obama was a lawyer for better
or worse you know what a game the system
tons of lawyers I mean the conversation
with uh Glenn Beck and DeSantis I I did
watch it and that's that's where
DeSantis wants to be but he's struggling
with
um you know how does he engage Trump
because he watched everybody get chewed
up and spit out when you when you take
on Trump uh playing on Trump's Turf
Trump's going to kill you so he's this
this this episode that we're talking
about DeSantis is like do I engage do I
disengage what do I do with this because
I know what happens to everybody that
goes toe-to-toe with Trump in terms of
uh uh you know a pissing match he says
that on the show he talks about that no
no oh but that's putting words in his
mouth he's never going to say that out
loud but that's that's kind of what I'm
saying is
if it's not going to be Trump it's got
to be someone who can easily go
toe-to-toe Trump you know what I mean
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time